Rebel football staff been out hitting
that recruiting Trail hard today they
announced their Spring Class 18 players
14 High School Kids four Junior College
transfers Rebels signed seven new
players through the transfer portal and
then when you look at all that's going
on in this town this weekend it's pretty
amazing you got the Eastway shrine game
pro bowl a lot of Big Time football here
in this town and UNLV can use all that
as a selling point for recruits but then
you look at Vegas and and you look at
the opportunity that's here you look at
okay we've got the Pro Bowl we got the
shrine game and we've got the Super Bowl
next year Vegas is becoming the sports
Mecca of
America that if you really take a step
back and look and think about the things
that we're going to accomplish together
in this program it's off the charts it's
really exciting all